Harvey once you say yes to a project
what are some of the first steps when I
take on a project I start researching it
looking back and seeing what it is that
they've done before or reading any kind
of background material scripts outlines
things like that if it's an artist I'm
listening to all the music they've
recorded listen to what the voices are
listen if maybe actors are and in the
case of some of these movies you're
looking back in the history of the music
that's going to be featured in the films
and kind of seeing ok what can I do to
these songs to make them contemporary
and relevant how far can i push them how
careful do have to be because there's
some classic copyrights there that you
don't want to tamper with so you start
researching it and then you kind of just
start laying out an organizational plan
on how you're going to attack the
project the latest film i'm working on
head i think 70 songs in it so you know
you have to be a little bit strategic
with how you do it my next project is
broken out into kind of three different
groups of styles of songs so I kind of
start organizing them the next step is
usually kind of start casting and
thinking about Who am I going to use the
directors cast in the film I'm casting
the music Who am I going to use to
create the right sound for each
individual piece of music and luckily
living in LA we have access to the best
musicians and best vocalist so I can
pull from mazing group of talent but you
really part of my job as a specific
specifically make sure the people I
bring in accomplish the sound that I
want for that particular piece of music
okay let's talk about sing then so once
they presented you with us maybe
descript and you knew who some of the
voice actors were how did you fit the
different songs for each character that
was a trick because there was so much
material and so many characters but
ultimately what the job was for me was
to take kind of the playlist they had
put together and figure out what was the
personality of each character and how
could I translate that into kind of a
sonic or a genre specific sound for them
so ash supports banjo edgy rockin you
know so we just knew the song that she
was going to do had to have that edge
reese's characters very pop and kind of
cleaner cut pop pop artist so those
songs obviously kind of led us down that
sound so you really it was about
recognizing the personality of the
artists and then just figure out which
songs work for that and then ultimately
making sure that I gave them that
consistent sound now once you decided
which artists you were going to use what
is your process are you contacting the
songwriter or are the artists themselves
performed it what's the process like
getting approval once the songs were
chosen and approved by the director in
the heads of the studio there's another
person that works with us his name is
Jojo Villanueva he's the music
supervisor so his job was specifically
to go in license and clear all these
songs I think he cleared almost a
hundred pieces of music so that process
involves going to the publisher going to
the artists record companies performers
all those people depending on if we're
going to use the actual master recording
or we're going to recreate it just
canned there's a couple variables there
but he has to reach out and negotiate
all those fees and prices and usages and
that's a nutty job he's been doing that
but for saying for almost two years big
job whether some songs that you
presented and you thought you know this
would be a great match when they had
Elton John you had Stevie Wonder Leonard
Cohen but other people didn't think it
was a match and your process for proving
your point or working with them maybe
just turning over the control to what
they want what was that like well to be
honest I didn't I didn't choose a lot of
the songs I added my my opinion and
there's a few songs I brought to the
table but a lot of the songs were chosen
by the director and so because he chose
those songs there wasn't a lot of people
we had to prove it to you know maybe
Chris milodon do the head of the studio
but for the most part it was really
Garth knowing the songs he wanted and
then how do we make those songs work in
the context of the film and that was the
position I was in like Garth loves a
song but he doesn't know how to piece it
together how it's going to fit and he's
not even sure that it is so if anything
I'm almost taking his idea and trying to
prove it back to him like yeah I got
that's a great song title let's figure
out how we can flip it
in other cases like the grand finale
songs there was some uncertainty about
some of those songs and we went back and
forth we tried three or four different
songs in different spots and I would do
little rough demos don't you worry about
a thing was one in particular where we
did a lot of versions of a lot of
improvements to we started at one place
and Mike we started over here and we
ended up way over here on that song so
ultimately you're just trying to create
the right emotional feel and just hit
the right beats for the direction for
the story with the music so you're
choosing the songs based off of that but
once they've chosen you know you can
take a song ten different ways in
production is all how you produced at
the tempo that key the key the
instrumentation so as long as I was
aware of what the song needed to
accomplish I was able to take those
songs and manipulate them to kind of fit
the scene
you